[Music]
when we're about to break a dubious
record lake mead is nearing its
lowest level of all time that number was
recorded
in 2016 when the lake was at its lowest
point
since the 1930s and to go along with
that the boulder
harbor is closing because water levels
are just so low it's basically unsafe to
enter the lake
governor steve sisilak is taking a
proactive approach to the crisis
he signed a bill that gets rid of
non-functional turf or grass that
never gets stepped on we've identified
that there are approximately 5 000
acres of non-functional turf in the
valley that accounts for about 12
percent of our water use
if mandatory water usage cuts are put in
place california and arizona would be
harder
hit nevada would use credits from
previous years to offset any cuts
our state may face and here's the fact
for you the biggest water users are not
strip properties or homeowners
the most water in our state goes to
farmland the strip only uses about four
percent
of our water